abbas et nos numéros 5 et sexy numéro 5
ayant ces gens me jean-michel hier soir
j'ai regardé le magazine de la santé sur
france 5
voilà et alors tout le monde n'a pas
l'occasion où les moyens de voyager de
descendre le nil donc là il proposait
une invitation à une exposition
culturelle à paris la cité des sciences
et industries
voilà une expédition un voyage
initiatique j'ai trouvé très intéressant
je vais dîner ce week-end il exactement
c'est pas sur le nil mais c'est après du
nil quoi sur un voyage à tunis
c'est drôle le nil qui se trouve qu'ils
se trouvent où des en énergie oui mais
attendez à quoi bas c'est bon on demanda
et l'autre ça y est la fait de bêtises
c'est bon calme-toi la ville d'el non
mais tu va redescendre moi je te le dis
hein il son histoire des cendres de
plusieurs imams est la racine carrée de
16 du mal à la trouver racine carrée de
16 est connue le siala tact du cul leur
ego les vélos veine il a un quoi calmos
quand même allez on regarde qui n'a
jamais eu envie de voyager à l'intérieur
de son tube digestif et bien c'est
possible maintenant grâce à une géniale
exposition à la cité des sciences bien
du script on y entre par la bouche on ne
ressort par la lucie et on découvre sur
le chemin le microbiote intestinal et il
y en a bien d'autres des choses pas très
ragoûtante comme l'hérault
l'aspect du vomi ou encore la
consistance des selles
pour moi c'est l'impression qui se
rapproche le plus de la position
naturelle
accroupis comme ça et puis si un peu
sans se penche un peu en avant mais au
moins la position est idéale
[Applaudissements]